this is crazy like five big YouTubers
have just quit the platform forever
discourse is wild I mean why is it even
happening is YouTube over all right
let's watch one of these goodbye videos
and hear about the drama hi guys I'm a
hugely successful content creator not
anymore quitter sometimes it's just time
to move on because things suck because
things are great oh and I want to end on
a high oh it's over YouTube has
destroyed this once happy man turning
him into a husk of his SC well not
really end I'm just going to be scaling
back production making fewer videos and
focusing more on my second Channel
incredibly successful easier Productions
Andor podcasts I have reached a level of
success on this platform that I can
afford to do the things that I want at a
pace that I want to do them things are
changing but I'm happy about it and I'm
excited for the next phase of my
career this is a tragedy of the highest
order